this may come as a surprise to about
three people given how many times it's
already leaked but 2k games has
confirmed that bioshock the collection
will be releasing later this year I'm
lucy-ann would you kindly watch this
game spot news update bioshock the
collection is a remastered anthology of
bioshock 1 2 and infinite it'll release
this September on ps4 xbox one and pc so
not only will the collection contain all
three games it'll also have all of the
DLC that was ever released for them
additionally it will include a
director's commentary feature called
imagining Bioshock with director ken
Levine and lead artist Sean Robertson
but if you were hoping to get back into
the action in BioShock tues multiplayer
you're out of luck buddy because the
remastered version of bio 2 will not be
letting you splice and dice online but
you do get the most excellent DLC
Minerva's Den so I guess I kind of makes
up for a couple of notes about the pc
version of BioShock Infinite included in
the collection according to 2k it's not
being remastered because it already
meets current-gen consoles standards and
run smoothly on high visual settings the
compilation is being developed by blind
squirrel gangs who collaborated with
irrational games on the development on
the original release of BioShock
Infinite we'll have to wait and see how
the remastered versions of the Bioshock
games fair but the original versions all
received glowing reviews from gamespot
Bioshock the collection costs 60 bucks
and releases on sep tember 13th for ps4
xbox one and pc so there's always a
lighthouse there's always a man there's
always a remastered collection are you
going to dive into rapture or ascend to
Columbia once again we miss bio tues
multiplayer let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games for more on bioshock
make sure you keep it gamespot